pleasure to see you again this time I've
now seen the movie so I want to say
congratulations
their relationship is so unique and cool
and different when you were researching
and when you were discovering everything
what really struck you about their
relationship like what really impressed
you um just how kind of pragmatic and
open mind didn't open hearted it was I
think that comes from a very solid
foundation of this kind of clarity of
sight that they had for one another from
very early on and so when approaching
the kind of unforeseen trajectory of
their relationship they were able to I
knew be much more understanding and like
I said pragmatic about it rather than
trying to as we do so frequently now
trying to find a relationship and put it
in a kind of category or a lay under a
label whereas with this they kind of let
it be what it is and I think we can
learn a lot from that yeah and it's also
was so ahead of the curve yeah you know
what I mean yeah I keep using the word
modern to relate to that relationship
but it's a shame that you actually have
to say that in 2018 um I speak to a lot
of actors and they say they cannot watch
them like they attend a world premiere
and they they start the movie and they
say hi and then they are like in a pub
because they cannot watch themselves on
screen is that you know I mean the
watching myself is the one why I mean
the only way that I can really
thoroughly like learn from what I do
frequently my face doesn't do quite what
I thought it was doing um so it was a
good education but also with this kind
of film where it was such a huge
collaboration with all of the cost and
crew and such a great energy on set
every day really feels like a family
piece so it'll be good to celebrate with
everyone and see everyone's work come to
life uh yeah I'm sure it was a hard sell
when they said oh the world premiere is
gonna be at Wembley Stadium yeah I think
do I want to get to that or a pub well
tegu million right the thing about Queen
is that no matter what songs were
included in the movie there's gonna be
like 20 that are still amazing that
weren't included yes so what was the
song that you were disappointed
make the cut um I don't know I guess
I'll put you on the spot yeah I didn't
know I didn't think cuz now the one I
was gonna say is I believe the credit
song no I think that actually the main
joy was hearing songs in it that I
wasn't previously aware of as shameful
as that is to admit um so that's the
kind of exciting thing that they've
taken the place of the ones that had a
sing-along to the live aid stuff in the
movie is spectacular and it has this
amazing energy and you can I would
imagine at the premiere on Tuesday like
the crowd is gonna sing along it's so
good what was like being part of that
sequence and how challenging was it to
shoot definitely challenging for the
guys pretty much I mean the easiest
thing for me
all of those reactions are entirely
authentic it was my first day on set it
was actually bookend at the experience
from it was my first day on set and the
very last when we went back for reshoot
and um I mean it was just shocking
seeing them recreate every moment beat
for beat every turn of the head or nod
to one another so that was just such an
electric energy and then to have to
actually witness the crowd that we have
respond in that way calling the calling
back and the kind of the clapping and
stomping along it was incredible so
hopefully they'll feel similar or
Wembley I'm hoping that it's gonna be
like that because that would be amazing
yeah I'm always this movie is one of
those rare films where if it had been
five hours I would have been happy
because just so much of the story so I
am curious were there any deleted scenes
that you remember and what can you share
there are a lot of scenes that were
longer than they are now in the film you
get we had more of Freddie and Mary in
the apartment and stuff kind of building
up to when he introduces the band name
queen you had actually the explanation
of of the emblem which was fun but but
no the timing and kind of pace of how it
is work so well now but you can't miss
them be you get to wear some cool
outfits oh yes what did you borrow from
set that you might return at some point
I'm still trying to borrow my entire
wardrobe but the one piece that I covet
more than anything is that purple coat
that you first see Marian which i think
is a one-piece I absolutely gone half
but we'll see if I can borrow I was
that's one of those things were you just
complain you're not feeling good while
you're wearing it upset just run home
yes
exactly where what what poeple could
pública exactly doesn't ring a bell
exactly exactly I'm not mistaken you
might be on Ryan Murphy's new show yeah
so what can you tease about this thing
because I looked at the cast and it's
pretty good it's pretty great
um it's called the politician it'll come
out next year and I'm too afraid of
hunting or of the Ryan Murphy Empire to
tell do anything um I heard political
comedy yes yes very much
it is dark and it is funny and it's very
topical subjects that it deals with a
relief that we're talking about them in
touch away
Ryan is a major power player in
Hollywood he has been known to create
some really good content what was it
like meeting him for the first time
terrifying yeah yeah I don't know what I
didn't know what to expect it's kind of
like meeting the Wizard of Oz um and
then you realize he's just really nice
very kind of very very present with you
and very funny sassy says yeah he's an
incredible human being
um that note congratulations pleasure to
see you again thank you so much good to
see you
you